here at home Clark County also
remembering the thousands of live loss
21 years ago on this tragic day Victoria
Saha has more tonight
one day that brings First Responders
survivors and the public together to
reflect on the heavy emotions that
surround September 11th
[Music]
Clark County held its annual never
forget 9 11 ceremony starting at 9 11
A.M amongst those in attendance was
retired to New York City firefighter
Frank Pizarro as I'm watching the TV
I witnessed the second building gets
struck and at that point I said
not an accident Pizarro was supposed to
have the day off but as he saw the
towers crashing down he rushed to his
fire station in New York City's Upper
West Side to respond to the scene with
his team and I said
a lot of guys are going to die today 21
years have passed
some years of good some years not so
good
this year not so good nearly 3 000
people lost their lives that day
including hundreds of First Responders
Pizarro leaving a message for those
looking back on that day honor your
military and your First Responders
because they've sacrificed their lives
for people they don't know
and go into Harm's Way
when some of us run away
[Music]
Sunday's ceremony was another reminder
to make sure we continue to honor
remember and never forget what 9 11
means
Victoria zaha 8 News Now
the ceremony continued with a classic
car show a DJ and food attendees were
able to help paint a 911 mural as well